anybody with grown kids
you have grown can you help your kids
27 and 31.
what's that
you say she's a milf take it easy dude
yeah you know it's weird having because
you know
he he's still just as dumb
like as he was when he was a teenager
anybody have teenagers in here anybody
get teenagers
nobody's got a teenager all right good
you do in the back what do you got
21 21
yeah and 19 is what boy or girl
boy he's pretty dumb right
[Applause]
does he laugh like this
that's how you laugh i know that a
hundred percent
how old are you dude
yo a teenage boy is the dumbest
[ __ ] walking that is oh
yeah it's not your fault man you're
gonna get smarter but it's gonna take a
couple years you know what i mean
how old are you dude
21 21 tonight [ __ ] yeah man
[Applause]
thanks for breaking out the puka shells
for us bro you know what i'm saying
now 21 what are you going to do after
this
casino
and all these people who are these
people with you tonight
your friends
[Laughter]
girlfriend best friend best friend's
girlfriend the two girlfriends are best
friends
everybody's [ __ ] at that table
[Laughter]
i'm just thinking what you all were
thinking too yeah i have a [ __ ]
everybody's [ __ ] at that table
[Laughter]
i've seen his dick her [ __ ] and her
[ __ ] yeah
happy birthday everybody
[Laughter]
what are you drinking 21 year old
a blueberry mule
a blueberry mule
did you get a vagina for your 21st
birthday
can i have a blueberry meal
can you put an umbrella in it it's my
21st birthday
listen
[Music]
can you get him something that's not a
blueberry mule
something stronger
and and just make sure it's uh it's on
you guys but uh
yeah who's your who's your weight person
i'm not sure what you're supposed to say
anymore who's your server
who's your server
a lady
i'm sure she'll be happy to hear that
hey lady
[Applause]
hey [ __ ] it hey lady uh
can you buy uh can can we get the puka
guy
actually the whole are you
are we getting [ __ ] up
hey can i
you're not a lady
can you get them four shots of
tequila
this these four
hey
hey hey
five one for me
um yeah uh
we're going to the [ __ ] casino
tonight blue meal
[Music]
yeah
how does it feel to have a drunk mom
here everybody
whose mom is that who's mom raise your
hand who's mama's at
oh it's none of you guys are with her
[Laughter]
they're like i don't know this [ __ ]
old lady i don't know her
wait how old are you for oh-ho-ho-ho how
old are you guys
how old
are 17.
wait and how are all four are you 17 how
well that deep voice that's not 17.
i heard that dude no i drove the 17 year
old
how old are you deep voice how old are
you
24 yeah what about the rest of you guys
18. 16.
hey i just got one question 24 year old
what the [ __ ] are you doing out there
there
i'm just hanging out with the kids
that's all i'm doing
no you you you drove and you're the
responsible one yeah yeah yeah and so
um
how did you guys find yourselves here
tonight
huh
no i didn't mean are you guys [ __ ] i
just meant how did you find your way
to the show
we're just friends
you're a little defensive bro you know
what i'm saying i'm not fingering
anybody we're just friends
oh okay okay okay
[Music]
all right just so i'm glad we got to the
bottom of that ho ho
yeah dude i was like this dude's
drinking his milk through a straw we got
a [ __ ] puka shells
we got the harry potter team back here
yes
what
i hear you chatting over there i'm just
who the [ __ ] is it because you're
basically mumbling under your breath and
the only person you're bothering is that
dude sitting right next to you
so is it something do you want to say
out loud
okay then keep it in your mouth
yeah if you don't want to say it to me
then just
oh is it just two
oh you're cheering
happy birthday hey everybody
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you still trying i like it man you know
what i mean
by the way
[Applause]
my man wants to be on that milf train
tonight so if anybody
yes sir
i'll tell you so this how old are you my
man 31 31 okay what would you consider a
milf
yo that is a [ __ ] wide
yeah i like that well everybody listen
all you need to know is this dude is not
choosy
and
if you have kids he's [ __ ] down to
[ __ ]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]